well from rock to pop let's pick up
where we left off with our exclusive
inter
interview with backstreet boy member aj
mclean yesterday we shared the first
part of the one-on-one
interview our producer natalia had with
him and today we shared the second part
of it in which she
had to ask what is his craziest vegas
memory
show 58 out of 82 shows
when we had our residency here i will
never forget it and
neither will our dancers or our
production manager i
fell through the stage during the show
uh about 12 feet straight down bounced
off the riser onto the cement
uh i don't remember much because i was
in shock
but uh that was uh that's gonna
that's gonna itch when it dries let's
just say that that wasn't a clean burn
wow the backstreet boys larger than life
residency kicked off
in 2017 at the zappos theater inside
planet hollywood
that residency was only meant to be nine
shows total but
as you heard aj the larger-than-life
residency ran for a total of
82 shows the best thing about vegas is
that it's such a hub
for international audiences from all
over the globe that come into vegas
for the weekend to have a good time it's
unlimited what you can do
with any of these vegas shows you've
seen it with cirque du soleil
with chris angel with blue man group
with the countless shows here so
we can't wait to come back here
hopefully for our 30th anniversary
which is only two years away yikes it's
crazy hey
a mood is that a hint his back straight
back all right
can't believe the backstreet boy's 30th
anniversary is just two years away
big thanks to aj for taking some time to
talk to us all right we can't see what
aj and the band are going to be up to
next and don't forget you can stay up to
date with the latest from aj
on all of his social media platforms and
online via ajmclain.com
you've seen the residency show have you
not yes i actually got to present them
an award for
the 25th anniversary of i want it that
way the song i got to go
on stage that's awesome and present them
with this so it was a lot of fun it's
hard to believe
that we're celebrating these big
anniversaries i know it was just
yesterday yeah just 10 years ago they
were
talking about 30 years all right